[Music]
[Applause]
Al leiter joins us now he won three
World Series titles once through a
no-hitter back in 1996 when he was with
the Marlins you can watch Al on MLB
Central plus MLB Network's live coverage
from the World Series gets underway
today at three Eastern ahead of
tonight's game Five on Fox Al joins us
on the program Al was that a no-hitter
last night
uh yes it was dead no hits or not
allowed by the Astro pitchers I I hear
you I you know what part like we just
have to get past that
as a baseball fan here's a guy who in
game five of the 2000 World Series I
threw 143 pitches we ended up losing to
the Yankees but I was appreciated so
appreciative to this day that Bobby
Valentine kept me in the game uh unlike
last night where there's a chance for uh
Javier to come back and maybe into game
seven so it all plays in yeah we lose
potential Great Moments
for probably the right move of not
having a guy stay in but likely he would
have had to throw 130 140 pitches if if
they kept him in to throw no hitter yeah
I had no problem with what Dusty did
Dusty's got to win a World Series now he
doesn't have a manager a managerial
World Series he doesn't give a damn
about history he he doesn't want to be
history from the standpoint of the
Phillies an improbable World Series
Victory and I'm not a big analytics guy
but I think he you know he made the
right decision obviously in the moment I
thought yes you take him out this kid's
25 he doesn't pitch usually past you
know six or seven Innings and no issue
with it and if you feel like your
bullpen's ready to go you know he'd made
the right move
no no doubt and and the bullpen being
lined up look I I mean unless people
really Bear Down on the Astros all year
and we know what kind of roster I think
before uh you know the postseason you
probably would have figured you know the
Dodger Astros I know the Yankees you
know kind at the end maybe went a little
sideways but uh I you know I had no idea
as good as uh Abreu has been this guy's
Elite Montero has found a home Presley's
been good so like Dusty's got a lot of
options so when you have the ultimate
three or four or five different options
he's got a couple starters that would
likely start on other teams if they were
on another a club with uh with Carson or
Katie there's a lot there for Dusty so
yeah this is a hundred percent was the
right move
um how's this play out Al
right Phillies have to win tonight I I
do not see the Phillies going down in
Houston winning two in a row I just
don't I I just the first of all the
Astros are that good and you know the I
was down just as a fan to watch game
three you know Citizens Bank was amazing
obviously you know they went from five
home runs and done and blowing out the
Astros to get no hit the next night but
uh there is an advantage but the only
Advantage is is that you have to get
your crowd behind you and in order to do
so you got to score early you got to
figure out a way to make it compelling
so that that you add a little more
pressure to
uh the opposing pitch and staff and uh
we'll see you know Verlander's is you
know he's going the Hall of Fame he's
going to win another Cy Young so I think
he should have ice in his veins and if
there's a way that you can create an
early run that's what you try to do
but the Philadelphia I mean really
exciting even just as a guy who Once
Upon a Time played I I it was easy to
kind of get caught up in the excitement
of the home crowd we've made a lot out
of Lance McCullers maybe tipping his
pitches how often does it happen
think it happens a lot I think it
depends on on uh certain hitters I'll
give you a quick snapshot Dan uh when I
was with the Blue Jays veto Gaston our
manager who's a long time hitting coach
he was excellent at picking up something
and then therefore once they found it
there were certain guys Paul Molitor
didn't want it like there was multiple
times where I would hear like Joe Carter
or Robbie Alamar a couple of other guys
that that wanted the tip and I would ask
I would ask Molly and he's like no I
don't want it because if I know it's
coming I'm jumping out of my shoes and I
end up swinging at pictures that I
normally wouldn't because I know it's
coming so there's a there's a so many
there's a variety of different things
that pitchers can do to alter just the
smallest minutia of a delivery and once
you identify that it's incredible how
obvious it is so I I don't know I don't
know if if McCullers didn't want to
admit to it or you know but it looked to
me that there was something going on so
uh yeah yeah
I if I'm the Phillies I would have said
yeah he was tipping like I want to get
into his head I want him to go wait what
was I doing and and and then you know
when he comes back if they're you know
game seven then all of a sudden he's up
there thinking that's that's what I want
to do we're talking to outlider MLB
network analyst uh your buddy Bruce
Springsteen was at the game did you see
him I saw that no but I he was there
last night I was at game three so oh my
God I I watched uh I watched and
listened to the uh the Howard Stern
interview I guess is the first time that
Bruce was ever on yeah did you did you
watch it or hear it I heard a lot of it
oh my God what's fantastic
you know just well Howard could pull it
out of people right he kind of disarm
you as you do and I never heard Bruce
like go into detail of some real
personal stories yeah I wish I was there
last night to be able to go over and say
hi to the boss uh and we have some
exclusive audio of uh Bruce Springsteen
when he was on our show well I
all right let's go Phils
the Jersey Shore State Parkway
you know what bothers me okay
Springsteen baseball fan Al he said that
he could throw the speed Ball by you why
not say thanks
yeah no he couldn't I joked with my kids
because Bruce was very good to me over
the years um you know going to concerts
and stuff he was just great and uh my
kids when they were little I told him
that he wrote that song for me and my
kids were lost
because they I know I was like you know
I would go to the concert you know how
like the crossover you know everybody
being nice to people
um and then I finish them like no he
didn't sing that for me I mean excuse
all right I know you gotta go I know you
got to be on TV thanks for joining us by
the way
she's on there I think Smokey's been
doing great and about to sucking up I I
really enjoyed uh listening to him
breaking it down I actually was texting
my son I was like listen to this man
he's got some good stuff
thanks Al
right see you Al later you can watch out
on MLB Central plus MLB Network's live
coverage from Citizens Bank ballpark
gets underway three Eastern head of
tonight's game five yeah Allied our
loves Bruce yes he does you remember the
time maybe four or five years ago we had
Allied are in studio and you asked do
you have Bruce Springsteen's cell phone
he said oh I do and it's one of the
greatest accomplishments of my life to
get it you said would you text me I will
not I will not text him I will not
bother him he was like very very serious
about it he was not goofing around no
but then he did he did but like you had
he was and I said have you heard back
from him and he goes no that is just the
worst I didn't reply of all time because
you already did something embarrassing
and then it just hangs out there and
then Al was like oh I never should have
done that it's a huge mistake I said oh
it was great just to see you squirm and
you know it a couple of times during the
interview did you hear from Bruce yet
did you hear from Bruce huge mistake
yeah did you hear from Bruce I wonder if
he's heard from Bruce since then
I hope so
that's been a few years ago